hello everybody
going back to the 1950s today and
talking about the man the myth the
legend
vincent price sexy ass been surprised
sexy ass vincent price
in this movie yeah when he before he was
you know before he was like super old
before he was super old yeah well 70's
rolled around he was super old i mean
we're all still cool we're all getting
there yeah he was always cool that
[ __ ] was always cool i mean he
had a really really long career yeah he
was funny
yeah hilarious well i don't know if you
know this but he was also like a little
bit maybe in his later life was also
like something of a gourmet and uh him
and his wife put out like at least one
cookbook maybe more than that yeah yeah
and he was like his food huh yeah yeah
yeah he's a foodie yep
so yeah he's just like seemed like an
all-around cool guy yeah so we're
talking about the tingler uh a movie
that uh the porn version could have the
same exact title and no one would know
any different
yeah this came out in 1959 i kind of
love these old
1950s like creature features this one is
almost kind of i guess i never really
thought about this but i was like watch
another review of it and they kind of
said there's like almost like some proto
cronenberg [ __ ] going on in this and i'm
like yeah it's almost kind of like a
body horror like an early body horror
type of uh
monster situation you know what i mean
which i didn't really think of until i
was like until somebody mentioned that
so
this was directed and produced by the
late great william castle
now
anybody that knows anything about this
era of horror william castle was like
the gimmick guy
i think this was like his third movie
that he did
uh with the same writer prior to this
he'd done one called macabre
and his gimmick on that was he'd give
you like a thousand dollar life
insurance policy if you died a fright
during the movie so you know he was
starting out small
uh and then the next one uh which was
the second one that he where the first
one that he did with vincent price was
house on haunted hill the very famous uh
which has been remade and [ __ ] like that
and that one the gimmick was emergo
where the skeleton like would come out
from like during the part in the movie
where the skeleton like came out
in the basement or whatever like a real
skeleton would come out in the theater
like on a wire and it would like go over
the crowd or whatever so
you know what i mean
now
well yeah but it's like there's
something kind of charming about that
you know what i mean now this one this
movie actually kind of has two gimmicks
which i actually get why he did it
because one of the gimmicks is like in
camera like in the film
and then the other gimmick which was
really expensive but could only be like
at limited theaters um you know that
since it was in limited theaters you
might not get that gimmick so at least
there was another gimmick in there
you know what i'm saying no so the
gimmick for this one
well it
yeah you do i'm talking about
you guys know what i'm talking about you
guys know what i'm talking about no
because i'm saying you had you had a
gimmick in the film yeah being
uh the film's in black and white but
there's one sequence where a woman is
unknowingly tripping on lsd we'll get
into it um and that's she actually is
tripping on lsd in the movie and
you see like some visions where there's
like the bathtub and the sink is like
full of blood and the blood is like
bright red
in a black and white movie in a black
and white movie so that was one gimmick
but the other gimmick which was only
limited theaters was something called
percepto with a exclamation point on
that yeah
percepto
what this was was in some theaters
they rigged some of the seats with
see i think william castle in his
autobiography i think he said oh it
would give you an electric shock it
wasn't that it was just like a little
vibrating i actually think they got it
for from
uh what i heard was that it was parts of
like a de-icing motor like from world
war ii planes or something like that and
they would just like rig them in some of
the theater seats like in the bigger
theaters like in big cities and stuff
and then during the part of the movie
when the tingler was supposedly loose in
the theater they would turn all the
lights out and then some of the seats
would vibrate
and
in the movie like the only way to get
the tangler off of you is to scream so
everybody and actually in some of the
theaters too they had like plants in
there like they had people
that would like get up and faint and
scream and [ __ ] like that so they'd kind
of get the ball rolling yeah so they did
kind of like a big
i mean it sounds super fun i would have
[ __ ] loved it probably didn't work
i don't know this is 1959 i mean you
have to get into the spirit of the thing
you know what i'm saying yeah um you
know i actually would like to see it i'd
like to see like a revival of it where
they had all the gimmicks people had
less to do back then that's what i'm
saying so it's like probably fun but
like i said it still sounds like kind of
fun you know what i mean even if you
didn't get the vibration and i like that
they even
um
they say because william castle like
does the introduction at the beginning
and he even says well not everyone is
susceptible because not all the seats
have the [ __ ] because like i said i
think the gimmick cost him like
a quarter of a million dollars half a
million dollars something like that it
was like some hugely a big amount and
pushed the budget like
doubled yeah doubled the budget
yeah well and probably and they had to
like pay people yeah stooges and stuff
too
uh that that would like act in the in
every uh you know showing so they had to
do that as well so i'm sure that uh
contributed but i don't know it's just
yeah it just seems like kind of just
like a fun i would really really like to
see like a revival of this for like 1950
you know with all the 50s stuff and like
where they turn on the lights you can't
turn all the lights out the exit lights
had to stay on obviously in case there
was a fire but other than that they
turned all the lights off and they got
people to scream and some of the seats
vibrated and [ __ ] like that so i just i
don't know i thought that was like a
cool idea it's it's my favorite one of
his gimmicks you know what i'm saying
and honestly it's like william castle
like i said he's kind of known nowadays
as the gimmick guy because that's kind
of what he did um and he was pretty
successful at that but you have to think
one uh from everything that i've heard
about him he was like the nicest dude
imaginable and two he actually like
produced some good [ __ ] he produced
rosemary's baby
so like the movie um so he did do some
goods it wasn't just all like 50s
gimmick kind of stuff
so this movie here
what is this movie what is the tingler
about if you haven't seen it
so vincent price plays he's a
pathologist i guess uh dr chapin i think
is his name
and he's noticed
that
people
that die like some people that die like
in a state of extreme fear
that like their backbone like their
spine is broken and he thinks like you
know it's [ __ ] just roll with it
and he thinks that's like really unusual
it's just like there must be something
doing that right so he's trying to like
figure out what it is so he's doing like
some mad scientist kind of [ __ ] on the
side
now what he eventually discovers um and
he kind of like proves it later on
is that inside of everybody's spine i
don't i wasn't real clear on whether
everybody's just born with it or if it's
like some kind of parasite that kind of
comes in your body later i think you're
i think you're reading too much into it
well that's kind of what i do though
they hadn't thought that out either i
mean it's kind of a cool it's kind of a
cool idea i will say because what it is
is they said hey you know how i mean
essentially they took the phrase like
spine tingling and made it like literal
there's something in your spine that
does that it's a parasite i guess yeah
and like the more scared you get yeah
like the bigger it gets and then if you
get so scared that you can't
scream or you get like overwhelmed then
it will like kill you and it'll like
break your spine while it's trying to
get out or something like that i
remember as a kid when i saw it it
scared the [ __ ] out of me this
[ __ ] the
he pulls and vincent price pulls with
the [ __ ] tingler out of somebody's
spine
out of a dead person's back yeah
you only see it in shadow and it looks
like a big old
centipede yeah and then it [ __ ]
camera angle changes and he's got it in
his hand and it starts biting him and
ready he's going
and he's fighting it and it scared the
[ __ ] at me when i was a kid you see it
now and it's just like uh it's it's the
little creature actually
looks pretty good it's actually pretty
good for 1959.
it looks like
i mean i'm sure it was just like strings
or something like that but it looked
like it was like alive and i couldn't
really you know it kind of like it kind
of humped around like that and like i
said if you don't like creepy crawlies
or centipedes or something like that
then it would absolutely like probably
freak you out because it's got those big
feelers and those little feets yeah i
was just even watching this movie as an
adult is difficult for me to follow you
know i mean
it's kind of boring or never plotting
not really boring it's just kind of slow
by today's standards a lot of talking
which is well a lot of 50s movies
and uh not a lot of showing
and i kept getting confused
was this was the tingler invent was it
invisible was it transferring from one
person to the next i had no everybody
has their own but they had their own
right everybody okay
there's a sentence i never thought i'd
say everybody has their own tingler okay
um what happened evidently
well no that's that's the whole like
point of the story so okay so he didn't
really realize he's like well there has
to be something in there and he started
a suspect there was something in there
so what he did
one thing that i love about this too is
that there are two married couples in
this because i kind of feel like this
movie had like a little bit of like a
black comedy element to it too vincent
price and his wife the way they snipe at
each other is [ __ ] hilarious because
his wife in this is just like this
complete
hussy man and she's like totally not
ashamed about it or anything like she
just like cruises it she's like making
out with her boyfriend like on the lawn
like in front of the house it's like
vincent price looking out the window
going wow look at her go you know what i
mean it's just kind of this whole thing
and he's like yeah you know how come
every time i come in here like uh come
in the front door i hear the back door
closed she's just kind of like mom i
don't know bro why could that be she's
like totally not hiding it yeah but yeah
i mean
yeah well and you have to believe she's
a terrible person i'm not saying that
like and they paint her as that because
it's not just that she's [ __ ] around
on him because that could almost be
forgivable because he doesn't pay any
attention to her because he's always in
the lab but
she like compounds the error by she also
has a sister
who uh they live in this big palatial
estate apparently she's uh the wife has
got all the money right she's the one
that's paying for all of vincent price's
uh you know
science and stuff yeah and um
so even though her sister is clearly
like
30
um she's like oh well i have
guardianship over her and she can't do
anything i don't want her to do or she
won't get any of daddy's money because i
have control of all of it and the sister
wants to marry
uh this guy dave that is vincent price's
assistant
and the [ __ ] sister is just kind of
like nah that's not happening for some
reason it for some reason yeah well she
doesn't like dave she well no because
she thinks that dave is going to end up
just like vincent price like you're
going to ignore her just like you ignore
me it's like y'all can be in the lab
like the whole time and it's like i
don't want that to happen to her that's
her excuse anyway but like i said the
the wife is a terrible person but
deliciously so she's like such a [ __ ]
and it's amazing i love it i love her
character it's 50 style 50 style yeah
problems i just really really i mean
they are literally like threatening to
[ __ ] kill each other like all the
time and i just love how [ __ ] brash
she is about all the [ __ ]
affairs that she's having and just like
this [ __ ] [ __ ] that vinci vincent
price says to her like about it um you
know just it's just great like all the
lines between them was just like i think
that's probably my favorite part of the
movie it's just the two of them like
sniping at each other thing about the
movie that [ __ ] always got me is that
he pulled that thing out of the spine
and that thing wouldn't fit in his spine
without you not be able to see it it was
pretty massive
well yeah well
that's well kind of the thing is
the thing that he said at the beginning
like i said it doesn't have to make too
much sense it's a 50s sci-fi creature
feature but
he did say at the beginning that if you
had so much fear in your body like the
more fear that you had like the bigger
it would get so it's not that big
usually okay you know what i mean um and
the reason that the one that he pulled
out of that one woman was so big was
because she was a deaf mute and she
couldn't scream okay and so she was so
terrified that it got really big and
then busted out and killed her yeah okay
right right really i didn't really yeah
it's they are they weren't all that big
because what what ends up happening is
that vincent price to like test his
theory before he knows that the tingler
is a real thing it's it's just
theoretical
never been observed ever before right
hundreds of years of [ __ ] autopsy
yeah but like i said the excuse for that
could be
in animals that they're little yeah and
you know unless you get so terrified and
you can't you know let that out then
it'll stay small so nobody'll notice it
it's like it's plausible deniability i'm
a destiny i'm willing to give the movie
the benefit of the doubt 50 seconds i'm
willing to yeah
well you know 50 science that's what it
was that's some 50 science you know the
heart is one big cell it's yeah
yeah i remember that what movie was that
uh i think that was the amazing colossal
man make any goddamn sense i'm like
because i i saw that movie on mystery
science theater they said well we all
know that the heart is one big giant
song i'm like no it's not we don't know
that what he talked about
mr science emails also don't know the
difference between a solar system a
galaxy or or anything
yeah i mean like
they're going to leave our galaxy to
leave our galaxy we have to to to enter
the solar system and they'd say some
crazy [ __ ] like that like they don't
know what yeah
it seemed like they used those two terms
like uh interchangeably and i'm like
they're those terms are not
interchangeable completely different
things we're gonna go to that
we're gonna get into this rocket ship
and go to the center of the galaxy it's
it's five million miles away
oh it is okay no it's not yeah but yeah
a million miles away all right now
really like other than the tingler
science in this which you know it's fine
now vincent price does say one thing and
i'll give him a pass because people did
actually think this probably up until
the 60s or 70s i think was that uh your
hair and your fingernails keep growing a
little bit after you die
um for a long time people did think that
that is absolutely not okay pulls away
from uh yeah the skin just like kind of
shrivels and pulls so it sometimes it
looks like uh that but they don't
actually keep growing after you die
but yeah so
so theoretically he he knows there's a
tingler like theoretically that can kill
people
uh that can you know make people die of
fright right
so he decides that the best way to test
this theory
is he's going to
shoot his wife as you do yeah um
so
what you might have to you never know
when that that situation might occur but
um or shoot your husband or your
boyfriend you know just just saying
you don't know what's gonna happen yeah
but yeah so
he doesn't really i mean he does want to
shoot her i'm gonna shoot her dead i'm
not saying that but he just wants to see
he pretends to shoot her like with a
blank because he wants her to be like
really terrified
so he can see if the [ __ ] is in there so
he does that you think she's dead he
yanks her onto like the x-ray thing it
takes x-rays over back and then he sees
it in there so he's like oh my god it's
like an actual creature that looks like
this little doohickey now
prior to all this he happens to meet
this guy
who was a friend of somebody he was
autopsying and wanted to come see the
autopsy again as one does
and it turned out that this guy and his
wife owned a movie theater that played
like old silent movies
now it turns out that this guy's wife
who he also wants to kill you find that
out later on
is a deaf mute and she can't scream she
also has some other issues she's super
super afraid of blood
and she seems a little ocd although i
don't think they bring that up in the
movie but she totally has ocd she's like
a germaphobe and everything like that so
she's got some problems
but so uh vincent price thinks to
himself hey
hit right here is a is a golden
opportunity because here is a woman
who's like super nervous and has all of
these like phobias and she can't scream
to release the tingler like to you know
get the tingler off her back literally
so he's like i'm i'm gonna go experiment
on that [ __ ] without like her knowing
about it now before he does that
he has his assistant bring him some lsd
yes lsd 1959 uh it was still legal
really i mean it was just kind of seen
as an experimental chemical acid they
were still like doing like i said
experiments on it so it wasn't termed
you know as a narcotic or anything like
that like it is nowadays
the attitude of the drug of drugs the
attitude about drugs
the modern person wouldn't understand it
it wasn't until like the the 60s and the
70s that drugs started to kind of become
controlled by governments really they
mostly didn't get it give a [ __ ] what
you did
they uh needed to sell [ __ ] laudanum
and opium through the mail back in the
1800s earlier well yeah you would again
that wasn't illegal cocaine wasn't
illegal didn't really think about it
they didn't care
um
you had something called right to bliss
which is your body if you want to take
it uh if you ask me i think the way it
should be
you know the [ __ ]
because there wasn't much money in it so
there's no reason to kill anybody over
it there's no drug cartels or anything
it's just not worth anything really
until it's illegal then all of a sudden
it's worth gold and then they use
governments with it and i mean the thing
is like we've talked about this before i
don't want to get too far off the off
the topic but i mean as long as people
aren't like [ __ ] driving around or
anything like that but you know we
already have alcohol like that like
alcohol so you know the same kind of
[ __ ] should apply
so he decides he's going to take some
lsd because he's like well i would
experiment on myself but i'm not afraid
of anything so i don't know how that's
gonna work so he's like well maybe i'll
take some lsd and that'll freak me out
and then you know i can experiment on
myself so there's a great scene where he
takes some lsd he injects it actually in
his office and then he starts to go
like all it takes effect like
immediately which i'm not sure if it
does i guess it would be a lot faster if
you injected it like rather than like
ingesting it like you normally would
because it takes a while but it's pretty
much immediate and he's like [ __ ] starts
tilting and he's like the walls the
walls
and then he's kind of like thinks the
skeleton is like [ __ ] with him and he
thinks the well he thinks that the um
that the window is locked he's he opens
it and he's like i'm locked in even
though the window is like clearly
opening so he's like freaking out so
like i said he's experimenting with that
he's like okay that works pretty good so
i'm gonna go uh unknowingly like give it
to this
mute woman and see what
happens so he meets up with the theater
guy and then he's uh the theater guy's
like yeah my wife's not feeling too well
he's like well i'll go up there and see
what's going on so he's like here's this
injection it's just like a sedative it
won't hurt you nothing like that and
then she has a [ __ ] freak out she
starts seeing like poltergeist activity
um you know she sees like this dude with
like a melty face and he's like [ __ ]
with a machete or something there's like
a werewolf hand like throwing a
hatchet at her all kind of crazy [ __ ]
and then like i said she goes in the
bathroom and the the sink turns on and
it's red like red blood and like i said
she had a blood you know phobia and then
the bathtub also fills up with blood
like this bloody arm comes out of it and
[ __ ] like that now they said
i don't know if i'd entirely believe
this they said that how they shot those
two scenes
was that
it was color film but they actually like
painted everything black and white
you know to it and i was like i'm not
sure i buy that because
some of it looks like they could have
done it like that when it was just like
the sink in the wall and [ __ ] like yeah
they could have done it like that and
i've seen that done before
but there's some parts especially where
she's in it i was like they didn't paint
her entirely black and white that just
would have looked weird and
the the part where it's her and like the
bloody tub it's like way grainier even
though the movie's been restored it's
actually on 2b for free if you want to
watch it and that's like the restored
version and it looks like really crisp
and beautiful except for that one scene
like is real real grainy and i think
that's why because i think maybe it's
some kind of like uh you know they had
to do like a color layover or something
like that that made it like kind of
fuzzy so i kind of feel like that's what
they did but some of it's still sharp
and that's the ones that i think that
they just painted the set black and
white without the actress in it you know
what i'm saying because that looks
alright
but so she sees that and she dies
and then vincent price is all kind of
like okay well um you know she's dead so
we might as well like uh you know
contribute have some science uh you know
contribution to science and so he takes
the tingler out and it's like super big
and then it escapes
and so because the tingler gets out
and
the
the couple like where the the wife died
live above the theater
the tingler like gets down to the
theater so that's kind of how they do
this whole
meta thing where if you saw this in the
theater back in 1959 they'd be like the
tingler is loose in this theater then
like the seats would start to vibrate
and like people would start screaming
and they turn the lights off and all
this other kind of [ __ ] and like they
also like listen to their commitment to
this gimmick they also re-recorded some
[ __ ]
that said the tinglers loosen this
drive-in
so that even if you saw it in a drive-in
theater you'd still get like the correct
right thing and i was like
like i said that's commitment this he
thought of everything william castle
so
so yeah so
it gets out like everybody's flipping
out and they're everybody so they start
trying to get anybody to scream like i
said it's like audience participation
and then they end up like catching it
and then vincent price says well maybe
the only way we can kill it because it's
apparently indestructible is if we put
it back into the host
right so they have to put it back into
the dead woman at which point you find
out that the woman
even though vincent price did actually
inject her with lsd
that
i guess she was like tripping out but
her husband
actually wore the costume and like did
all the [ __ ] in the room that was
scaring her not the blood stuff i don't
think he could have pulled that off but
all the other stuff that she saw like
the rocking chair going back and forth
and the scary melty face dude with the
knife and all that that was him so he'd
been trying to kill her and he thought
hey maybe i can scare her to death now
that i found out about this tingler
business so he actually did kids so
vincent price is like oh by the way i'm
turning your ass in
so there was that whole thing too but
then it ends up like the guy ends up
dying because when they put the tingler
back into the woman she like sits up and
stares at him like all creepy
and uh then he dies a fright so it's
what goes around comes around there's
the that kind of [ __ ] too but yeah so
this is just i don't know this to me
this is like just a really charming
uh 50s monster movie i love the gimmicks
i just i really like that i just think
that's like super cute and i think it's
cute that they thought of that at the
time you know and i think if you saw in
the theater it would have been like
really fun
and you know i although like i said i do
actually think the creature is pretty
effective because i mean it's obviously
kind of fake and rubbery and stuff but
if you're kind of grossed out by bugs or
centipedes i mean it's probably pretty
it'd probably be kind of upsetting so
there's that
you know yeah
not me you don't like it no not really
it's
uh
it had it been shortened you this might
have made a pretty good uh twilight zone
episode
there's just too much movie here for for
what it is that they're trying to do
not enough payoff um
but
probably pretty good in his day you know
a lot of the 50s sucked
um
you might be able to i don't know you
you give this to cronenberg and he he
actually might
come up with something how awesome would
that be if david cronenberg yeah or
brandon chrono brothers
uh they could remake the tingler they
don't have to call it the tingler
because like i said that sounds like a
sex toy yeah but you just call it
something else but it could totally be a
remake of the tingler yeah it was like a
different name
it just wasn't for me that would be
pretty awesome
one thing i i like like i said probably
other than like the little monster my
favorite thing is just the way that
vincent price and his wife like snipe at
each other like the [ __ ] [ __ ] they say
to each other is like hilarious
um and also
i just i don't know i just kind of feel
like it had like a really good like
black comedy kind of tone to it and i
just i don't know i just really kind of
got into that i also love that vincent
price this is why everybody still talks
about vincent price and loves him to
this day
is that as ridiculous as the premise of
this movie was as cheap as this movie
was it was just like a gimmicky creature
feature
he committed he took that [ __ ] seriously
he always did he always did and i think
that that's kind of why he has like such
he's so lionized in the horror community
because he never
laughed at the movie he never
um half-assed it he came in and he took
it seriously and he actually gave the
best performance that he could and i
think that that is one of the things
that actually kind of makes this work is
that well he makes this move yeah i mean
he's saying like ridiculous things like
like i said the science behind this is
kind of ridiculous but he just says it
with such conviction that you're almost
kind of like okay i'm coming i'm kind of
buying it he's tripping out the kids
yeah so you know
he does sell this movie yeah this movie
would have been long forgotten without
him it's it's a terrible premise but he
he is pulling out the stops to try to
make you believe this [ __ ] yeah your
[ __ ] uncle vincent
you know trying to put one over on you
yeah exactly what it is exactly he's
definitely trying to put one over on you
yeah he knows he is but he's not like i
said he's not making fun of the material
or anything like that he always was like
really professional yeah he's just
trying to trip you out yeah and i said i
just think that's like so great is it i
don't think this is as good as house on
haunted hill because i [ __ ] love
house on haunted hill we don't think
we've uh i don't think we've done house
on haunted hillary um but yeah actually
because that's like more a murder
mystery type thing um but this one's
like a lot of fun too and you know it's
weird i was like watching last night and
the guy that plays dave in this i was
like that guy looks like super familiar
and so i looked him up and he was
actually in i mean he was in movies back
from when he was a child actor like back
in the 1930s but he was in some movies
that we reviewed like from the early 80s
he was in looker
and he was in sharky's machine
he was like detective smiley yeah and i
was just like god i knew he looked
familiar i thought he was in some other
he was in a bunch of other 50s movies
this is what you watch when you're in a
50s mood and you're gonna watch like a
couple of 50s movies back to back you
know raining outside and [ __ ]
lightning and [ __ ] you're drinking you
could what you do yeah this is actually
a good one i think this is a good one
you don't take any of these movies
seriously they're just there to [ __ ]
try to trip you out yeah although
compared to some other 50s movies i've
seen this is actually really nicely shot
like it has like some really good uh
framing and like some kind of moody
atmospheric kind of stuff this is one of
the memorable ones yeah i mean there's a
lot of them that you just people don't
even remember that's how bad they were
right this is one of the good ones yeah
it's just not one not one of the top
good ones it's just yeah this is it's
probably like like i said like probably
like b-tier this is like a b-tier like i
said i don't think it's as good as house
on haunted hill uh which also had
vincent price and his wife sniping at
each other wanting to kill each other
now that i'm thinking about it uh he
seemed to do that a lot in movies but um
it's not as good as that but
i think that those two movies would
actually these two movies would make a
good uh double feature i think house on
audit hill and the tingler so you can
kind of watch those two together but
yeah i'm gonna take like them
yeah i don't think we've done we haven't
done that one yet have we do them yeah
we haven't done enough 50s movies i feel
like
so you know blob
yeah
um although that one i kind of like the
remake better from the 80s which and i
don't say that lately i can war the
world
now we did do that yeah we did do the
fitness that's the world forbidden
planet that's top tier 50s yeah
this one like i said it's it's just kind
of like a fun it's a fun bee movie it
wasn't aspiring to be anything else it
wasn't supposed to be like a master of
cinema or anything but given that it's
actually much better than it needed to
be let's put it like that if you were
growing up in the 70s back on [ __ ]
saturday
at saturday [ __ ] matinee they'd
[ __ ] play the [ __ ] monster movies
yeah and this is like one that would
come up and it would scare you
in the middle of the day you're watching
this [ __ ] you're getting scared it's all
right i'll forget about it by the time
you go to bed and yours and then you go
to bed and like you think there's a
tingler yeah right like a big [ __ ]
huge centipede like crawling on your
face
yeah it is like that but yeah so uh yeah
if you like vincent price and you
haven't seen this was definitely worth
watching it's on
2b for free at the moment at least as of
this recording so go check it out or let
us know what you thought about it and
that will do it for this movie
retrospective we'll see you guys on the
next one bye
you